because we had this pulled up before and
uh i'm going to tell everybody right now
before we read this article
i'll tell you the one thing everybody we
hear the most
of from guests and in conversations
not everybody says this and it's a small
minority people do
but we've had people come in and say i'm
more than happy to do the show so long
as you don't ever ask me questions about
transgenderism
or trans people and i'd be like i mean
if there's news there's news if there's
not there's not and i got to tell you
it's it's if someone comes on the show
and they're like i won't talk about this
and there's no point in asking because
they'll just not interact with you and
it'll be a really
weird conversation where you're like so
what do you think and they just don't
say anything so it's like
all right i guess and the reason for it
is
almost no matter what you do you get
attacked when you bring the stuff up
well i don't know what else to do but
yeah talk about it we have the story for
the new york post
cnn ridiculed for saying there is no
consensus for assigning sex at birth the
new york post reports
cnn is being ridiculed online for
insisting there is no consensus criteria
for assigning sex at birth
with critics telling the network to look
just below the waist for insight
the left-leaning network statement was
quickly shared online after appeared in
a news story wednesday about south
dakota banning transgender athletes from
women's sports
it's not possible to know a person's
gender identity at birth and there is no
consensus criteria for assigning sex at
birth
cnn's devin cole wrote critics quickly
ripped the outlet for reporting in a
straight fact
rather than attributing it to others and
noting differing views
quote i've gotten used to a lot of woke
craziness never thought i'd see
biological sex in scare quotes a twitter
user
wrote cnn isn't a news organization they
are straight up activists
online media critic lee zabatka wrote
while conservative commentator ben
shapiro said only an idiot
would believe the network's claim others
suggested a simple solution
i'm not a doctor cnn but if you look
just below the waist you may get some
insight
and then they just they're just quoting
a bunch of twitter users you're ragging
on cnn but cnn literally did this
when did this come out when does cnn do
that a couple a couple days ago last
week
yeah i mean the stories from yesterday
and we were thinking about talking about
a lot of people don't you know want to
bring it out to a hot potato
that's dumb it's dumb yeah can i talk
about it
no biological sex is real it is real
it's how we make more people yeah it's
you know we got that or this i think one
problem with this well
hold on hold on to be fair or intersex
right right so
it's so that that's that that's the
issue at hand is that
you you do have a lot of people who are
like it's either that or this
then you have people like you know dr
deborah soh for instance
who's very intelligent saying well you
know
it's bimodal there is an overlap but for
the most part it's overwhelmingly
you know male or female if you want to
have like an honest nuanced conversation
it's really difficult to have in
hyperpolarized times but i'm sorry like
i have a line
right biological sex is real to say
there's no consensus criteria for
assigning sex at birth
i don't like the phrase assigning it
that's very activisty
they identify you as the doctor sees and
says this is what the baby is
and they can be wrong and they have been
wrong there's some prominent
activists who are incorrectly identified
because they were intersex
like there's one woman who is actually
biologically male
based on dna and the issue was
i i forgot what what the syndrome is
called but
did not develop like the the testes did
not produce testosterone
so now they very much this individual
looks very much female even though
genetically is male
and so then when you have a doctor say
that and they realize that's not true it
doesn't fit how they feel
and they actually want to be a man like
yeah that makes sense these people are
real they exist
you know making sure we protect the
rights of all people is
part of the conversation but when you
get activists coming out and saying
actually there's no biological
sex it's like okay what i got from this
is there is this writer
said that it's difficult or challenging
to
establish gender identity at birth and
then immediately in the next sentence
said biological sex or as if they were
the same thing
no gender identity and biological sex
are different
yeah yep and they used to make that
argument that used to be their strongest
case they were like
gender isn't sex sex isn't gender who
would ever be
that's what i learned in my college
sociology classes
and now it seems like it's flipped where
it's like there's interchangeable
yeah i think that's due to the media i
think it's due to
a bunch of really dumb people who work
in media who don't understand things who
write about things and conflated them
and made the mistake
for real so what happens is you'll get
some like intellectual saying
well biological sex does exist gender is
the social constructs that have formed
around the biological sexes
and thus people could identify between
any of
you know any in between or outside of
gender
in fact if it is a simple social
construct then
certainly someone could make up their
own social construct and that's an
intellectual argument
and then someone who works for like the
new york times are having a postcards
biological sex ain't real because they
didn't understand the actual argument
being presented
over time it morphs into you're not male
so this is another issue i take when
they say someone is like
they're uh you know a transgender person
transitioned to male or female i'm like
no no
no between man or woman that was i
thought it was trans woman not trans
male i thought that was offensive to say
but it's really hard to keep up with
there's another reason why a lot of
people just refuse to talk about this
stuff
because what you say today could be
offensive next week it could be the
right thing to say today
offensive next week case in point wmixon
you got you do you know about wim mixon
wimxin have you heard that no it's women
within
oh yeah okay i didn't i've never heard
it pronounced yes
who knows so it's wim x in wimxin
uh the x is supposed to symbolize the
symbol for trans
and so they change the o2 and x it might
work in written language but in spoken
language it's confusing and people are
like
i didn't know what you know right
exactly i've seen it on twitter but yeah
yeah
it's a very very online thing regular
people probably don't understand
well when that word was made it was
appropriate
and then for some reason a month later
became offensive you know a couple
months later
some organization used the word and got
attacked how dare you
use that word trans women are women so
you don't need to say wimexin
then a year later they started using
webmix and again so it's like
no matter what you do someone will claim
someone will say it's wrong it's like
it's like i mentioned before the liberal
a circular firing squad or mexican
standoff where they're all staring at
each other waiting for anything they can
use as an infraction
so people don't want to talk about this
importantly i think don't don't ridicule
it
and and not publicly if you're going to
talk about it do not ridicule this
don't be mean to people yeah it's easy
as it is to be like well that seems
stupid to me so let's make a joke don't
do it it's not stupid to everybody and
it won't be in the future it'll probably
be more important to other people so
he's just
you know you know what bothers me about
a lot of conservatives is
their desire to be mean like i'm smarter
and better and you're dumb so i'm not
saying every single one of them but i
see it i see it a lot and i'm like
i don't like that you know i don't like
someone who's like
they would approach a story like this by
laughing and ridiculing and being mean
and i'm like dude but you don't win
arguments by doing that
you know a good example is when milo
yiannopoulos fat shamed a guy to jim
oh yeah and i was like i asked him i was
like why would you do that he was like
it works and i'm like
it already worked the guy's in the gym
now you're going to scare him off the
gym what are you doing man you know
like uh uh i understand there are people
who believe fat shaming works because it
makes me want to lose weight and get
active
but the guy in the gym you won yeah he's
doing it
he's like he's fighting that's the kind
of guy yeah
it's beyond not nice it's ineffective
like what's your real
goal someone actually was saying that we
were talking about
something about mental illness and uh
how we were being like kind of kind and
like
you know people need help people need
help in society but that i
have been too hard on people that are
obese and that i'm i'm treating it like
it's not a mental illness and i think
they might be right because i've been
you know i'm a huge foodie and into
sugar and
make the best of it make the best
everybody comes here and they're like
what was that
like inmate i'm like wow and i'm like
obesity is a pro obesity is a problem
and
i do believe obviously this problem but
i do not want to ostracize
people that are have that problem
this is a this is a guy ladies and
gentlemen who complains about the sugar
industry and then makes the best bread i
know
a little bit of sugar goes a long way
people people people yeah it's like a
fresh bread and they cut a slice of it
and people are like
impressed every time and then you go and
complain but the sugar's bad and
you're the one giving it to you two
teaspoons of uh white granulated sugar
for
five cups of flour four and a half clips
is that your secret technique
it was actually from paula deen i'll
give you the skinny that recipe is a
paula deen wrestling wait was she
was she the racist one yes yeah
i wanted to ask you have you ever
watched my 600 pound life no
i did and i was really struck by the
fact that i didn't watch it like as a
show
i've seen the commercials no it's okay i
watched 90 day fiance
it's okay so i actually i watched some
of it for a speech that i wrote and i
was like
it's never about food it's always about
something else these people are abused
they're being enabled they've been
manipulated they're being like
their parents will go out and bring them
to stuff because they can no longer
leave their house
and it's like it's not about food the
food is filling a gap and we're like
yeah in america we can use it we don't
use alcohol like russians do
always a coping mechanism yeah it is
scoping mechanism food i can see that
you were talking about uh conservatives
just being mean
not well i want to clarify too i'm gonna
clarify real quick yeah there are some
conservatives
that like being mean yeah they want to
trigger the libs and
do dumb stuff well i think a lot of
conservatives complain about virtue
virtue signaling which is true i mean
some stuff you just kind of have to roll
your eyes at people like i'm such a
great person blah blah blah
but i think on the right there's also
vice signaling
i've seen it a lot over this covet thing
where people take selfies with them in
the grocery store without a mask and
it's like
look at me it's it's it's the opposite
of virtue signaling it's the same thing
it's it is still virtual signaling
though it's just for their side
yeah i call it vice signaling because
it's yeah it's it's the same thing look
at how bad i
i can be yeah no no but yeah
it it it's effectively the same thing i
understand your point though by
signaling like
when somebody goes on twitter and just
insults and berates
somebody because the right is piling on
so i just i'm absolutely not a fan of
that stuff
yeah like the whole like um meghan
markle thing like i looked at this i had
no opinion about it but i saw a bunch of
conservatives attacking her and i'm just
like
did you care about this yesterday like i
didn't
they just want to be like rude i guess
i i got hit up by fox they wanted to
have me on
so a lot of people saw me on fox talking
about big tech and social media there
were some other instances where i've
recently been on fox as well
not on the tv on like radio and other
segments and
around the time of the meghan markle
thing and so i get an email from a
producer and they're like can you talk
about this and i was like i don't know
anything about the royal family
and they're like oh okay it was you know
it's big you have to have opinion on
everything
i was just like i purposefully avoid
nonsense
like the royal family does not have any
like it's celebrity gossip for americans
yeah we fought awards and i have to
worry about the real family i wonder how
frequently they hit up people and
they're like
uh the answer is always yes if i'm asked
to go on tv because it's good for my
career even if i know nothing about it
so you get a lot of these people just
feigning you know knowledge at least you
had the
the fortitude to acknowledge you didn't
you weren't worth
their time yeah i've used the
opportunity for your own selfish game
for for you know some advice i guess to
say you know
there are a lot of people who absolutely
are like oh man i can go on tv tell me
what to say
i never do that i'm like i don't have
anything to say about the royal family
i'm not interested
like i've been invited on a bunch of big
podcasts i say no oh my
what am i gonna talk about you give me
something i can talk about maybe i'll do
it
otherwise i don't know whatever i think
if people
just focus on themselves and what they
want to do and stay true to themselves
is their better path forward but uh
going back to the thing about
conservatives we
we know that there are a lot of leftists
who are virtue signalers
who will mock and grift and berate
people on the right or just not the left
and lie about them in order to earn
points i think a really good example is
this show
exactly i had a big argument with this
with his friend of mine
and what had happened was i made a post
about the chauvin trial
like here's what happened this is crazy
this is huge for the defense the defense
basically said
george floyd had odd before and had
similar symptoms at the time of his
arrest here
and we learned that according to his
girlfriend the dude with floyd was their
dealer so i'm like this is huge for the
defense
because uh a third degree murder in
minneapolis is if you provide a
substance to someone that kills them
that's your fault so that's this other
guy's fault
which could present very serious
reasonable doubt as to what happened
with floyd and who was responsible
and so you know someone comes in and
they say oh here comes tim paul's
confirmation bias and
all of his you know cult followers don't
want to read the actual news
and i had a conversation with this
person i was like you need to understand
what happened here
you don't watch my show you don't know
the opinions expressed on on this show
you don't know the opinions of the
people who comment on the show and you
look at it and immediately assume
if we are saying the defense got a
victory you know
in today's hearing you assume it's a
bunch of trump supporting red hat
wearing maga
flag waving people when in fact it's a
variety of people who are just paying
attention
you come in acting like you know
everything and everyone starts trying to
explain to you calmly and you get angry
this is what happens for a lot of people
they walk into a room where people are
saying wow the defense and the chauvin
trial this is big i mean it's not
perfect
and then often they're like what is this
a bunch of maga conservatives
you guys are all biased and then when
people try saying listen listen
here's the guy who was the dealer here's
what the judge said about the guy
about floyd putting the tablet in his
mouth and look i don't know what you're
talking about
i i watched rachel maddow so i know
everything
instead of having that rational
conversation they get mad and assert
that they're right and you're wrong
it's a really amazing you know thing i
think it's it's it's definitely a vice
when people assume it's not me who's
wrong
it's everyone else thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you